[Musica]
[Applauso]
a natale dell'anno scorso mi trovavo in
italia mia madre era in ospedale con un
tumore al polmone che se la stava
portando via io ho iniziato ad avere dei
brutti presentimenti e ho fissato delle
visite di controllo ed è stato durante
una di queste visite di controllo una
visita senologica che ho scoperto di
avere un tumore al seno era a gennaio
nel giro di due settimane ho avuto la
diagnosi esatta del mio tumore carcinoma
duttale infiltrante e ho avuto la
caratterizzazione completa del tumore
che tipo di cellule che recettori erano
espressi la dimensione la posizione
nella compagine mammaria a marzo
due mesi dopo la mia diagnosi ho fatto
l'operazione chirurgica per rimuovere il
tumore a maggio ho cominciato la
radioterapia e nel frattempo il mio
tumore veniva sottoposto a ulteriori
test ed esami
quando sono arrivati i risultati di
questi test è stato un altro momento
difficile il mio tumore era piccolo
i linfonodi erano puliti quindi buona
notizia ma era molto più aggressivo del
previsto
cattiva notizia praticamente un tumore
sardo come me piccolo ma agguerrito
il fatto è che il rischio era che il
tumore si ripresentasse e quindi alcuni
dottori spingevano per che cominciasse
la chemioterapia ma non tutti erano
d'accordo e quindi per decidere il da
farsi
la squadra di dottori che seguiva il mio
caso decise di sottoporre il mio tumore
un ulteriore test test genetico
questo è un test che analizza le
espressioni di 21 geni del tumore
sulla base delle espressioni di questi
21 gen i può prevedere il rischio che il
tumore si ripresenti se il rischio alto
la chemioterapia indicata il mio
risultato è arrivato a giugno ed era
intermedio e quindi non ho fatto
chemioterapia a giugno o ripresa una
vita normale e adesso sono qua
[Applauso]
sono stata fortunata fino a 20 anni fa
il trattamento per il tumore al seno
come il mio era chemioterapia per tutte
le pazienti era uguale per tutte le
pazienti ed era spesso inefficace ben
presto ci si rese conto che non tutte le
donne rispondevano alcune pazienti
ricevevano il farmaco ne subivano e
devastanti effetti collaterali ma non ne
traggono un beneficio terapeutico e
quindi la comunità scientifica iniziato
a domandarsi perché perché alcune donne
rispondono e altre no oggi sappiamo
perché
oggi sappiamo che c'è un immensa
variabilità nei tumori al seno
praticamente non esistono due tumori
uguali ed è per questo che non
rispondono tutti allo stesso modo allo
stesso trattamento per esempio ci sono
tumori come il mio che esprimono alti
livelli del recettore per l'ormone
estrogeno e questi tumori possono essere
trattati con una terapia ormonale ma ci
sono altri tumori al seno che esprimono
un altro recettore che si chiama hr 2 e
questi altri tumori possono essere
trattati con un farmaco che si chiama
air settina che agisce su questo
recettore sulla base dell'espressione di
21 geni come abbiamo visto nel mio caso
si può prevedere se un tumore rispondo
no la chemioterapia
questa si chiama medicina di precisione
e ha rivoluzionato l'oncologia medicina
di precisione vuol dire poter offrire a
ogni paziente un trattamento
individualizzato ottimizzato per il
sottotipo di tumore che quel paziente ha
per me
medicina di precisione ha voluto dire
andare nel giro di sei mesi da una
diagnosi esatta alla cura mirata per il
mio tumore sei mesi adesso vi voglio
fare una domanda
sapete quanto ci vuole per avere una
diagnosi di una malattia
neurodegenerativa come il parkinson o
l'alzheimer
vi do qualche numero nel caso della
sclerosi multipla due anni per il
parkinson un anno per la sclerosi
amiotrofica laterale un anno per
l'alzheimer due anni
e questo il tempo che ci vuole per avere
la diagnosi quando dopo 12 anni
la diagnosi arriva non c'è cura per
queste malattie sono incurabili e allora
la mia domanda è perché perché non
possiamo andare nel giro di sei mesi
dalla diagnosi alla cura per una
malattia come il parkinson
se ci siamo riusciti per il tumore al
seno perché non ci riusciamo per le
malattie del cervello
ora una risposta che può venire in mente
abbastanza semplice è che il cervello è
un organo molto complicato e questo è
vero io sono nero scienziato a ve lo
posso confermare
e così ma non è l'unico elemento secondo
me c'è qualcos'altro che manca ed è di
questo che vi vorrei parlare oggi
secondo me manca oggi in neurologia una
medicina di precisione come esiste per
l'oncologia non abbiamo una medicina di
precisione e neurologia oggi perché fino
ad oggi abbiamo dato per scontato che
non ci servisse abbiamo dato per
scontato che i pazienti che si
presentano con queste malattie siano fra
di loro più o meno tutti uguali ma è
così
prendiamo l'esempio dell'alzheimer
è possibile mostrare come progredisce la
malattia in un paziente con un grafico
come quello che vedete la mia spalle qui
vedete il tempo i mesi e qui vedete una
misura della memoria a valori bassi
corrisponde una perdita di memoria
quindi prendiamo un paziente diciamo che
abbiamo il signor carlo il signor carlo
avuto la sua diagnosi
poi la sua memoria è stata misurata
intervalli regolari per tre anni e come
potete vedere ci sono stati degli alti e
bassi ma nel complesso alla memoria del
signor carlo è peggiorata ora cosa
succede se mettiamo insieme i dati di
più di 200 pazienti
questo è quello che vediamo
questi sono dati pubblicati
voi cosa vedete a voi sembrano tutti
uguali questi pazienti
a me no io vedo pazienti che rimangono
stabili pazienti che peggiorano alcuni
precipitosamente altri in maniera più
graduale e cene un paio che persino
migliorano ma allora com'è possibile
com'è possibile avere tutta questa
variabilità
se tutti questi pazienti hanno la stessa
diagnosi quello che succede è che oggi
la diagnosi che possiamo offrire a un
paziente con l'alzheimer è una diagnosi
clinica che si basa sull'analisi del
sintomo che il paziente presenta è il
sintomo in alzheimer e perdita di
memoria
quindi tutti questi pazienti si sono
presentati alla visita con un sintomo
simile di perdita di memoria ma vi posso
dire che questi pazienti possono avere
un sintomo simile ma molto probabilmente
non hanno la stessa malattia
per esempio alcuni di questi pazienti
accumulano nel loro cervello un pettine
tossico che si chiama beta amiloide che
si accumula sotto forma di placche che
possono essere visualizzate
con diagnostica per immagini con pet
come vedete qui la presenza di queste
placche e un'indicazione diagnostica
molto chiara di alzheimer ma ci sono
anche pazienti che presentano
esattamente gli stessi sintomi dei
pazienti che hanno le placche ma nel
loro tessuto cerebrale non troviamo
amiloide questi pazienti accumulano
un'altra un altro pt de tossico che si
chiama tdp 43 questo tipo di demenza si
chiama lei cade appena stato scoperto
con la risonanza magnetica possiamo
analizzare alterazioni nella massa e
nella struttura del tessuto cerebrale e
possiamo identificare la presenza di
lesioni vascolari
queste a loro volta possono essere una
causa di declino cognitivo e quindi è
qui che entra in gioco la medicina di
precisione perché è chiaro che non ha
senso trattare tutti questi pazienti che
hanno patologie diverse allo stesso modo
non avrebbe senso per esempio dare a
tutti questi pazienti lo stesso farmaco
diciamo un farmaco anti amiloide perché
solo i pazienti che hanno l'amiloide
possono rispondere al farmaco gli altri
no eppure vi stupirà ma è proprio così
che abbiamo fatto gli studi negli ultimi
dieci anni perché fino a pochissimo
tempo fa non era possibile a
caratterizzare i pazienti ma oggi è
diverso oggi grazie al progresso della
tecnica abbiamo una
serie di biomarcatori che ci permette di
caratterizzare a livello molecolare la
patologia dei pazienti la capacità di
caratterizzare la patologia cerebrale in
ogni paziente è il punto di partenza per
lanciare una medicina di precisione e
neurologia
ma non basta e un po come nel mio caso
ho avuto quando avuto la diagnosi di
carcinoma duttale infiltrante quello è
stato l'inizio sono poi per identificare
ottimizzare il trattamento è necessario
conoscere altri elementi è necessario
conoscere la genetica è necessario
conoscere per esempio l'età del paziente
lo stato sociale ha un'influenza e il
sesso è importante conoscere il sesso
del paziente in alzheimer nel 2016 con
due amiche ricercatrici per curiosità
abbiamo iniziato a raccogliere dati
sulle differenze in alzheimer fra uomini
e donne
e sapete cosa abbiamo scoperto nella
maggioranza degli studi clinici
pubblicati fino a quel momento non erano
riportate le differenze fra uomini e
donne nella stragrande maggioranza degli
studi preclinici quelli fatti in animali
da laboratorio
gli studi erano fatti in animali di un
solo sesso o sono maschi o sono femmine
e quindi non era possibile studiare le
differenze non ci sono dati non è stato
pubblicato per dire se i farmaci che
abbiamo testato negli ultimi dieci anni
in alzheimer funzionino allo stesso modo
negli uomini e nelle donne abbiamo fatto
tantissime domande e abbiamo trovato
tantissima resistenza
la gente ci chiedeva e perché è perché
dovrebbero esserci differenze fra uomini
e donne abbiamo trovato moltissimi muri
ma abbiamo anche trovato moltissimi
colleghi entusiasti ed è stato sull'onda
di questo entusiasmo che abbiamo fondato
un'organizzazione non profit che si
chiama women's brain project che si pone
come obiettivo quello di stimolare una
discussione scientifica su questo
argomento
e ad oggi
tre anni dopo anche grazie al lavoro del
women's brain project sono moltissime le
differenze sostanziali fra uomini e
donne che sono state descritte in
letteratura in alzheimer
così come in altre patologie per esempio
oggi sappiamo che dal momento della
diagnosi di alzheimer
le donne progrediscono molto più
velocemente degli uomini e guardate
questa una cosa fondamentale da
conoscere da capire perché vuol dire che
il trattamento dovrà essere
personalizzato anche in base al sesso e
quindi oggi non ci chiedono più e perché
dovrebbero esserci differenze oggi ci
chiedono
e come possiamo usare queste differenze
e la nostra risposta è medicina di
precisione
se vogliamo identificare dei nuovi
metodi per la diagnosi la prevenzione e
la cura dell'alzheimer
dobbiamo conoscere e capire la
variabilità fra i pazienti e questo vuol
dire anche conoscere e capire la
variabilità tra uomini e donne
la buona notizia è che oggi abbiamo
tutti gli elementi nelle nostre mani per
lanciare una medicina di precisione in
neurologia abbiamo i biomarcatori che ci
permettono di caratterizzare i pazienti
abbiamo l'intelligenza artificiale che
ci permette di analizzare questa mole
immensa di dati e abbiamo la
comprensione abbiamo l'idea di quello
che ha senso andare a guardare nei dati
per esempio sesso dei pazienti
se lanciassimo oggi una medicina di
precisione e neurologia potremo cambiare
radicalmente la medicina di domani
sapete come mi immagino io una visita
neurologica nel futuro io mi immagino
che il paziente si sederà e il dottore
analizzerà i suoi sintomi clinici e poi
raccoglierà tutti i suoi dati
i dati genetici i biomarcatori l'eco
patologie
forse anche il microbioma intestinale il
sesso chiaramente e poi tutti questi
dati verranno inseriti in un algoritmo e
con un click
l'algoritmo dirà qual è il sottotipo di
alzheimer specifico di quel paziente e
sulla base di questo sottotipo il
dottore sarà in grado di indicare il
trattamento ottimizzato individualizzato
per quel sotto tipo specifico di
alzheimer in quel paziente in quell'uomo
o in quella donna riusciremo davvero ad
andare nel giro di sei mesi dalla
diagnosi alla cura per una malattia come
l'alzheimer
io credo che con la medicina di
precisione anche meno
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]